AND AN ATTORNEY SAID THE GOAL IS
TO GET IT BEFORE A JUDGE SO
A DECISION CAN BE MADE.
IN TONIGHT'S WHATEVER HAPPENED
TO SEGMENT.
THE TREATMENT OF LGBT
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT IS PART OF THE CHANGING
CULTURAL LAND SKAM IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IS IT GOING BACK WARD UNDER
A CONSERVATIVE ADMINISTRATION.
DOUG LOOKS AT THAT QUESTION
TONIGHT.
>> I AM A FOLLOWER OF JESUS
CHRIST AND THE BEEBL TEACHES
THAT MARRIAGE IS BETWEEN A MAN
AND WOMAN.
>> Reporter: THAT IS WHY JACK
PHILLIPS REFUSED TO BAKE
A WEDDING CAKE.
THEY SUED AND THE CAKE SHOP
DECISION WILL BE DECIDED BY THE
SUPREME COURT.
AT STAKE WHETHER
ANTIDISCRIMINATION LAWS CAN
FORCE UPON TO DO.
>> THEY CAN MAKE DETERMINATIONS
ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY MAKE
WEDDING CAKES AT ALL AND DESIGNS
THAT THEY PLACE ON TO A PRODUCT.
BUT WHEN A BUSINESS IS OPEN,
THEY REALLY SHOULD BE OPEN TO
ALL.
>> Reporter: THE DECISION WILL
OCCUR OVER THE U.S. CULTURAL
STANDARDS AGAINST GENDER IS
EVOLVING.
THEY FOUND THAT OUT THE HARD WAY
WHEN IT RESTRICTED BATHROOM
ACCESS.
THE BACK LASH WAS SEVERE.
NCAA AND NBA PULLED GAMES FROM
THE STATE.
AND FORCED LAW MAKERS TO ROLL
BACK RESTRICTIONS.
THE TRUMP FILED A BRIEF
MODERATING THE BRIEF.
THE TRANSBAN ON MANAGEMENT
ISINARIOED AND THEY MAY SERVE IF
THERE IS NO HISTORY OF THE
GENDER DISPORA.
AND MIKE PENCE SWEARING IN
RICHLE GRANLE SPOKE VOLUMES
ABOUT HOW MUCH STAND AROUNDS
HAVE CHANGED.
TO COMPLY WITH COLORADO CIVIL
RIGHT'S COMMISSION HE DOES NOT
BAKE WEDDING CAKES.
>> THE EMOTIONAL TOLL ON MY
FAMILY, AND JUST MY LIFE IN
GENERAL IS DRAMATIC.
I HAD DEATH THREATS AND HATEFUL
E-MAIL AND PHONE CALL AND
PROTEST AND A LOT OF THINGS
ACCORDING TO LIVE TO MY FAITH
AND SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
IT MAY HINGE ON THE VOTE OF